hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ich befinde mich wieder hier zu hause
bei meinen eltern dass sie ihre am
hintergrund von dem ganzen zimmer und so
und zwar wollte ich heute eigentlich
über so ein artikel sprechen mit denen
ich früher mit der bravo rande mich über
meine erste eigene wohnung und wie es
war alleine zu wohnen und dass die boden
relativ klein war darüber werde ich
allerdings heute doch nicht reden ich
bin heute morgen aufgewacht
wieso um 11 oder so sorry ich weiß es
ist ein freitag und normalerweise
arbeitet man da oder geht in die uni ich
weiß allerdings seien die letzten tage
ich krank und hatte gestern abend auf 38
grad fieber temperatur das ist halt nur
leicht erhöht aber ich war total fertig
und auch dann einfach mal irgendwie
zwölf stunden am stück geschlafen und
fühle mich jetzt ultra fit ich will mich
dort wird ein rabatt
ich kann auf jeden fall aufgewacht
direkt handy genommen in vitro tage
checkt instagram gecheckt und schon bei
instagram die ersten kommentare gesehen
von wegen ihrer lukrativen faker von der
ost ihm der sagt irgendwie man sollen
ihm geld geben damit man mit ihm reden
davon dass brauch erst mal nur so etwas
war warum macht man sowas danach habe
ich dann halt bei den mails gecheckt und
hab dann auch die mail von dem zuschauer
damit alex bekommen der dann auch
irgendwie meint er wollte diesen kräften
auf steam enden wird hat dann auch
gesagt bekommen dass er ihm geld geben
soll
luca ich wollte dich fragen ob du deine
zuschauer und co in einer deiner
folgenden videos vor abzockern waren
kannst denn die wollen nur dass man
ihnen was spendet und das dann doch an
den falschen luca das hat er mir nämlich
so als e-mail geschrieben und hat dann
auch noch ein bild an gefangen wo in
screenshot davon gezeigt hat wie weg
hier vorne bei den screenshot
eingeblendet also da hätte der halt mit
diesem kongress mit diesem feld kaum
kräfte bei steam und ehrbarkeit so bist
eigentlich der echte luca de oder und er
so wenn du nicht spenden kannst brauchst
du auch nicht zu schreiben was bis zu
fünf spaßt sorry ich beleidige echt um
geld leute aber was bis zu fünf spaß was
bist du für ein [ __ ] was bist du für
ein dummer spaß was bist du viel spaß
bei allem respekt dass ich leute echt um
gerne leidige aber warum macht man so
was du nimmst beide identität an um dir
damit einen finanziellen vorteil zu
erschaffen was bist du in der mail die
mit derart exakt geschrieben hat
schreibt er weiter es handelt sich
hierbei um die seite store.de power.com
bei der ich selbst mitglied bin das bild
zur abzocke findest du um anlagen und
die zweite sache die ich dich fragen
wollte ist ob diese gruppe aus die mit
einer der folgenden videos auch erwähnen
kann somit seine zuschauer die auf die
benutzer bla bla bla bla bla ich weiß
nicht was das für eine gruppe ist ich
will ja auch gar keine werbung für eine
steam gruppe machen ich komme überhaupt
nicht klar wenn es die mich mag auf
steam da ich viele fragen sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch luca wenn das ein
fake hals wie heißt denn du dann bei
steam
ich habe keine ahnung ich habe es die
methode auch wird irgendwie 40 spiel mit
allen möglichen cod egt a rocket league
minecraft ist gar nicht bei steven
glaube ich oder ich hab da halt echt
eine ladung voll und ich weiß auch nicht
genau ob ich das heißt ich weiß nicht
irgendwas mit büro- oder irgendwas mit
laser oder ich weiß nicht ich will jetzt
auch keinen namen sagen weil ich das sie
dann denkt sie haben gesagt das ist der
echte oder ist es doch nicht mein name
also kontaktiert mich nicht bei steam
und wenn ihr jemanden sehen dass bin
bestimmt nicht ich eine schreibt weiter
irgendwie so ich soll die gruppe
erwähnen damit leute wissen dass das die
rechte gruppe ist habe ich hab gerade
erscheint auch falls du auch ein steam
nutzer bis dann wäre es nett und 17
namen im nächsten video war ja ich weiß
halt mein team namens selber nicht also
wirklich wenn ihr auf steam seit und ihr
denkt ihr euch einen balkon crafter oder
so oder sucht den x oder so ihr werdet
mich nicht finden und wenn ihr mich
finden kontaktiert dann kann es sein
dass ich antworte indiens team bin wenn
euch allerdings jemand antworten sollte
dass es definitiv ein fake also passt
auf weil sowas das ist ja auch schon
öfters bei mir den youtube kommentaren
vorgekommen auch bei sehr vielen anderen
youtuber dass sich leute aufgrund dieser
scheiß google+ funktion dass man sich so
nennen kann die andere auch ich weiß
auch nicht was sich youtube dabei schon
wieder für eine kacke dachte aber auch
schon oft leute mit dem namen konkret
darüber geschrieben joho paysafecard
annual it for you und irgendeinen scheiß
und ich denke nur sowas es seid ihr für
untermenschen apropos youtube übrigens
ich habe hier so ein ebook von denen
bekommen da stehen gegen die alle kanäle
drin
da stehen meine ich alle kanäle drin die
irgendwie empfänger des coldplay button
2015 sind ich frage mich wie youtube
wieso kriege ich dieses buch im jahr
2016 macht ja sinn
ich meine das jahr 2015 geht ja bis ende
zeit aber ich bin auch blöd naja ich hab
das buch auf jeden fall vor 12 wochen
bekommen also sechs monaten 2015
abgelaufen ist und ich habe das auch
schon ganz modifiziert angepasst ihr
seht ihr noch ein paar andere kanäle und
da bin ich bin moslem porten channel ob
die am anfang wird gezeigt so hallo luca
beginnt das abenteuer ist damit ihr also
gezeigt so dass man der erfolgreichsten
videos waren mobilisiert wie viele
aufruf 320 millionen aufrufe hatte ich
und dann kann man dieser brief von
dieser susan wojcicki das ist irgendwie
die hobos tante von youtube wo sie den
brief nicht mehr begonnen mit lieber
lukas sondern einfach nur liebe youtuber
das ist auf jeden fall dieses jedoch gut
was ich von dem komma ist ultra coole
mich sehr darüber gefreut dank an der
stelle an dich youtube ein paar wochen
vorher haben die mir auch irgendwie
sondern youtube blätter mit mit gold und
irgend einen komischen schlaufen youtube
polizei wieso hat man dann einfach
schluss am ärmel ist definitiv der coole
jacke würde ich so auf jeden fall auch
spinnen längste dorf mit brawngp
2000 das komplette weiteres feuer wird
schwarzen wachmann auf die beiden sachen
die mir youtubes umgesetzt hat wollte
ich eigentlich gar nicht so großen
redebedarf gerade drauf anwenden aber
die larven auch noch rom und die wollte
ich euch aber zeigen und jeder youtube
gezeigt ich vollzeit job bekommen ja
super cool auf grund für dieses video
heute war allerdings wirklich der grund
dass ich diese mail bekommen habe und
bei instagram kommentar dass ich gezeigt
wurde
weil irgendwelche leute ist und
ausnutzen wollten dass leute meine fans
mich kontaktieren wollen und die das
knie oder schlüpfen bei denen noch geld
ab obwohl wir der typ gar nicht sind in
dem ich wirklich kontaktieren wollt dann
macht das bei instagram das soll
wirklich überhaupt keine werbung für
mein account sein dürfte aber trotzdem
folgen heiße der laser luca nur als
instagram halt wirklich so das einzige
soziale netzwerk wo ich in letzter zeit
wirklich durchgängig aktiv bin also klar
kommt auf youtube wenn ich es schaffe
kommt auf youtube jeden tag neues video
bei twitter post sich auch am tage wie
34 sachen allerdings bin ich auf
instagram so am meisten batterien und
kurse durch soll die kommentare durch
suizid durch und alles mögliche dauer
eigentlich am häufigsten welche
kommentare ein also wenn ihr wirklich
kontaktieren wollte und irgendwas sagen
wollt von wegen das im tec-dax bitte bei
instagram und damit will ich auch schon
das video endet meine damen und herren
ich bin der raw datei gerade bei 20
minuten ich weiß nicht wie ich so lange
über zum thema quatschen kann allerdings
war es einfach wichtig weil bevor jetzt
die leute denken dass das wirklich der
echte konkreter ist weil er hat halt den
namen kraft dabei ist die und dem land
gegen die 20 euro paysafecard geben oder
so habe ich gedacht ich sag's lieber mal
also ich habe ein fake aber ist die
meldet den monat besser gesagt ignoriert
es einfach wenn ihr von dem
angeschrieben werden oder den such oder
so schreibt ihm einfach nicht passt auch
mit pécs eigentlich habe ich über einen
verifizierungscode twitter instagram
youtube das war's aber ich sehe auch
komplett egal wenn euch das video
gefallen hat wie ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und dann sehen wir uns
morgen wieder in einem video für euch
dann
fenster nicht wahr